la kriegsmarine
le kaiser était fasciné par la mer ses
meilleurs souvenirs d'enfance était ce
passé à jouer à osborn sur l'île de
wight la propriété de bord de mer de sa
grand mère la reine victoria
le portsmouth il pouvait apercevoir des
navires de toutes classes
ils ont fait naître en moi le souhait de
construire mes propres navires un jour
et puis quand j'ai grandi de posséder
une machine aussi puissante que la
marine anglaise à la mort de son père le
kaiser frédéric iii en 1888
guillaume fut couronné en cours de la
nation la plus dynamique du continent
européen
un empire qui s'était développé
largement grâce à la politique habile et
volontariste du chancelier otto von
bismarck et à la puissance de l'armée
prussienne
guillaume était à réactionnaire il
savait que nombreux étaient ceux qui
encouragent l expansion de l'allemagne
afin qu'elles jouent un rôle dans les
affaires mondiales
l'industrie de son pays était
équivalente à celle de la grande
bretagne
donc pourquoi ne pas transformer cette
puissance économique en puissance
politique au niveau mondial quel
meilleur symbole pour une puissance
mondiale d'une marine puissante après la
chute de bismarck en 1892 la voie était
ouverte pour le nouveau kaiser et ses
partisans à partir de 1900 l'allemagne
commença à bâtir une puissances navales
et terrestres
quelles qu'en soient les conséquences
en 1906 les anglais lancèrent le premier
degré de notes un navire qui surpassait
n'importe quel autre bâtiment de combat
john fisher amiral de la flotte pensait
que le coût de construction de ces
nouveaux navires de guerre et
l'adaptation des bassins pour les
entretenir rendaient leur fabrication
par l'allemagne totalement inaccessible
le kaiser conscient qu'il ne fallait pas
que l'allemagne reste en arrière fit
approfondir ses ports et commença à
produire ses premiers cuirassé
la flotte allemande doubla de taille
pour la plus grande satisfaction des
responsables de la force navale comme
l'amiral tir pin's et des industriels
qui bénéficiaient des commandes
une course à l'armement se jouait entre
l'angleterre et l'allemagne en vue d'une
confrontation pour la domination du nord
ouest de l'europe
peu d'armes employées lors de la
première guerre mondiale exerçait une
influence aussi marquante sur la
conduite des hostilités que les
sous-marins
le pays est indissociable du
développement de la guerre sous-marine
plus l'allemagne
la guerre sous-marine se déroula sur
deux fronts distincts la guerre contre
les navires de guerre de surface et
celle contre les navires marchands au
début du conflit les stratèges navale ne
pensait qu'à la guerre de surface les
premiers grands succès allemand dans la
guerre sous-marine avait créé un
véritable climat de peur des sous-marins
chez lé commandant de la flotte de
surface et rendant parfois peu désireux
de risquer leur navire dans les eaux et
lee
en termes de pertes les sous-marins sûrs
qu'un petit impact sur les forces
navales
les opérations des sous marins contre
les navires de commerce n'était pas
envisagée à grande échelle au
commencement de la guerre
les conventions maritimes exigé que
l'équipage d'un navire intercepté soient
mises à l'abri avant que leur navire ne
soit coulé
l'habitude de lancer une attaque à la
torpille sans aucun préavis n'est alerte
mis un certain temps à s'imposer
ce n'est que lors de la deuxième partie
du conflit que la guerre sous-marine
sans limite de 20 général
le torpillage du lusitania fut la plus
célèbre des centaines de rencontres
entre ou beauté navires alliés ou neutre
le lusitanien fut attaquée écoulée le 7
mai 1915 en mer d'irlande causant la
mort de 1200 civils
la marine allemande décerna une médaille
d'honneur à l'équipage du sous-marin
tandis que la propagande alliés fustige
l événement et ces commémorations
parmi les victimes il y avait cent
vingt-huit américain cette action
s'avéra être un moment crucial du
conflit participantes à faire basculer
l'opinion publique américaine de
l'isolationnisme vers l'acceptation de
son implication dans la guerre
en 1917 l'allemagne un forte de plus de
100 vaisseau commença sa campagne dans
le but de mettre à genoux l'angleterre
au début la tactique fonctionne a comme
prévu les pertes maritime aux alliés
étaient en moyenne de 630 mille tonnes
par mois avec un pic à 8 166 mille
tonnes en avril 1917
ces pertes conduisirent à la mise au
point de principe de convois pour les
alliés une idée à laquelle l'amirauté
étaient hostiles
désireuse qu'elle était de garder sa
flotte de surface pour des opérations
plus conventionnel
au début 1918 les allemands étaient en
passe de perdre la guerre sous-marine et
mois après mois le flux
d'approvisionnement de matériel
militaire ou non vers l'angleterre
augmentait régulièrement en volume
les ou bottes ne pouvait plus renverser
le cours de la guerre et sauver
l'allemagne d'une probable défaite après
les premiers mois de conflit au cours
desquels il eu quelques affrontements en
haute mer la guerre maritime en surface
se déplace à dans les eaux européennes
la bataille du jutland qui eut lieu à la
fin mai 1916 fut la seule action de
grande ampleur de la première guerre
mondiale
l'amiral hypnos foncé vers la mer du
nord avec 5 3 heures face à la flotte de
16 navires de combat modernes commandé
par l'amiral franchir
il cherchait à entraîner la royal navy
loin de sa base anglaise
les deux flottes engagèrent le combat
une vitesse relative de 80 kilomètres
heure
il fut rapidement évident que l'armement
allemand était largement supérieur à
celui de la royal navy
quatre des navires anglais furent
durement touchés et un autre explosa
puis coup là
les navires de soutien anglais
arrivèrent sur place et comment certes
attiré sur la flotte allemande mais
n'arrivèrent pas à stopper les croiseurs
allemands
ceux-ci s'éloignèrent coulant un autre
croiseur anglais le combat durait depuis
90 minutes
les deux marines était engagé dans des
manoeuvres navales compliqué
en dépit de son armement bien plus
puissant la flotte allemande fut écrasée
par le monde
c'est ce qui décide à franchir à faire
demi tour
bien que d'un point de vue tactique la
royal navy et remporter cette bataille
ces pertes étaient bien plus lourde que
celle subie par la marine impériale
allemande
la marine allemande ne risque a plus sa
flotte durant le reste de la guerre
le 28 octobre 1918 les autorités
allemandes ordonné à la flotte de se
regrouper en mer et de lancer un raid
dans la manche
ce dernier ordre semblait être une
simple gesticulation décidée par les
officiers plus intéressés à sauver leur
réputation que la vie de leurs hommes
le moral des marins étaient
dangereusement bas
il ressentait intimement l'arrogance de
leurs officiers la dureté de la
discipline et les disparités des rations
entre les officiers les hommes les
équipages de deux croiseurs le touring
gun et le heligoland se mutinent air et
et tenir les chaudières de leur navire
4 novembre les dockers et la garnison de
qu'il se joignait aux mutins et
formèrent leur propre comité de
travailleurs et de soldats
les comités de marins n'était pas
déloyaux envers le gouvernement
ils rencontrèrent des représentants de
ce dernier qui les assurait qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'assaut contre eux première
des conditions de vie meilleures
avec prime à la mer la fin de l'état de
siège et la libération de tous les
prisonniers
en 1918 la guerre était perdue
la flotte allemande de haute mer fut
conduite à la base de scapa flow dans
les orcades
les navires de betty être désarmé mais
la marine impériale allemande fit un
dernier coup d'éclat face aux ongles
elle saborda tous ces navires de combat
croiseurs et destroyers
la décision de feindre torse de saborder
la flotte coûta à l'allemagne tous ses
navires de guerre
mais le succès de l'opération leur
permis de garder la tête haute
lors de la signature du traité quelques
semaines plus tard au château de
versailles
un chapitre du traité stipulait que
l'allemagne devait abandonner ses
navires de guerre aux alliés
grâce à fon reuters l'essentiel de la
flotte été détruites
et les vainqueurs repartir donc de
versailles les mains vides à la fin de
la guerre le reste de la puissante
marine de l'allemagne fut démantelé
selon les termes de l'armistice de
l'autorisant à conserver que quelques
petites unités pour la défense côtière
la construction de tout nouveaux
bâtiments seraient soumises délimitation
de taille ainsi tous les navires
allemands seraient bien plus petit que
ceux de n'importe quel autre pays lors
de la seconde guerre mondiale le rôle
joué par la puissance navale ne fut pas
différent de celui joué au cours du
conflit de 14 18
son premier rôle était de sécuriser les
océans pour s'opposer aux flottes
adverse afin de s'assurer que les
liaisons maritimes soient maintenues
au début de la guerre le cuirassé
demeurait le type de navire principal
pendant la course à l'armement
hitler avait décrété que la marine
allemande devait être assez forte pour
égaler la flotte anglaise
débute alors un programme de
construction ambitieux en revanche le
grand amiral est riche raider commandant
en chef de la marine pressentait qu'un
tel plan était sans espoir est que
l'allemagne ne pourrait jamais égalée en
surface la puissance de la royal navy
à la place ils penchaient pour un
programme de construction de sous marins
afin de pouvoir couper les liaisons
maritimes britannique
en conséquence le programme de
développement navale le plan z était un
compromis
il y aurait quelques nouveaux navires de
ligne et une mise à niveau de la flotte
existante
le schleswig holstein était le dernier
cuirassé avant l'ère des dreads note au
déclenchement des hostilités ce navire
était considérée comme dépassée
il avait été engagé dans la campagne de
pologne est utilisée intensément pour
bombarder les zones portuaires comme
celle de temps
le navire entrant dans le port avec des
troupes d'assaut à son bord
pendant l'attaqué le bombardement ne
s'interrompent y peint et durera toute
la journée et la nuit suivante
le port polonais qui était également un
important dépôt de munitions étaient
très bien défendu mais finalement après
s'être vaillamment battu les polonais
capitulaire sa mission achevée le
schleswig holstein se rendit dans le
golfe de punk pour poursuivre ces
bombardements des défenses côtières où
il fut rejoint par son sistership le chl
eysines
cette opération avait ouvert la voie du
port de gdansk pour les navires de
transport de tous
une enquête avait fait partie de
l'allemagne jusqu'à la fin de la
première guerre mondiale
et hitler était déterminé à la
réintégrer au reich par la force si
nécessaire
le 2 septembre hitler avait prévenu les
alliés qu'ils se retiraient de pologne
s'il était autorisé à conserver que dans
ce qu est le fameux couloir polonais
haider fut convoqué à la chancellerie au
matin du 3 septembre et fut informé que
la grande bretagne avait déclaré la
guerre à l'allemagne
hitler était embarrassé par son erreur
de jugement concernant la réaction de
l'angleterre à son attaque et finit par
admettre
je n'étais pas capable d'éviter la
guerre avec les britanniques après tout
reder observe affreusement notre flotte
de surface et 6 inférieure en nombre à
la flotte anglaise qu'elle ne peut rien
faire d'autre que montrer qu'on peut
mourir courageusement l'amiral grave
suspect était le troisième des cuirassés
de poche allemand mais allait devenir le
plus célèbre le 13 décembre 1939 alors
en mission contre les navires marchands
dans l'atlantique sud
il fait fort c'est de rejoindre
montevideo par les croiseurs britannique
ajax h il est exact heures
la bataille qui suivit mis à jour les
faiblesses fondamentales du concept des
navires blindés car le graff p n'étais
pas assez rapide pour semer les
croiseurs rapide anglais
et ses tourelles triple de 280 mm
étaient dépassées pour engager les trois
cibles très mobiles
exit heure fut cependant durement
touchée mais le graphe b fûtes endommagé
pendant le combat est forcé de s'abriter
à montevideo pour réparation
induit en erreur par des anglais
laissant croire que de puissants
renforts était proche lansdorff reçu
l'ordre d'hitler d'éviter l'humiliation
de la reddition de son avis
le 17 décembre le graff p se saborda
dans les eaux territoriales uruguayenne
sous le commandement de langue dorff le
graphe suspect avait coulé neuf navires
pour un total de 50 mille tonnes
pas un seul de ces marins officiers ou
passager ne perdit la vie dans ces
opérations
dans une dernière lettre écrite quelques
instants avant son suicide
lambsdorff écrivit un capitaine ayant le
sens de l'honneur ne peut pas séparer
son propre sort de celui de son navire
je peux seulement prouvé par ma mort que
les forces combattantes du troisième
reich sont prêts à mourir pour l'honneur
de leur drapeau
le charme horst fut lancée le 3 octobre
ce navire rapide et robuste peser 32
mille tonnes
son sistership le gneisenau fut lancé
deux mois plus tard
ces deux nouveaux navires correspondait
à une nouvelle définition du navire de
guerre qui sacrifiait le blindage au
profit d'une plus grande vitesse
le charme horst et l'ogc nice now
passèrent la première partie de la
guerre en mer à traquer les convois de
navires marchands dans l'atlantique nord
en 1939 il intercepté un convoi au large
de l'islande
escorté par le rawalpindi un navire
marchand converti en croisera
il fut coulé par le scharnhorst mais son
sacrifice permis aux convois de
s'échapper
le charme horst held by the now
échappèrent à la home flûte britannique
et retournèrent sans dommage à leur port
d'attache l'objectif de toute cette
affaire était la guerre commerciale
nous n'étions pas le seul navire de
combat dans l'atlantique les croiseurs
blindé qui furent plus tard rebaptisé
admiral cher gilles graf ge paie déjà
été engagés le cheikh était notre modèle
et avait déjà été couronné de succès
nous avons reçu l'ordre de mener nous
attaquent selon les mêmes méthodes
c'est à dire de naviguer et de trouver
autant de convoi et deux navires
marchands que possible de les détruire
ou de les capturer
et dans ce cas de les ramener à bon port
les britanniques avait déjà ajouté du
blindage à leurs navires de commerce et
former des convois pour leur protection
certains étaient armés et parfois
accompagnés de cuirassés ou deux
croiseurs nous ne nous risquerons pas
toujours affronter un navire qui pouvait
avoir un meilleur armements que le nôtre
ce qui pouvait avoir des conséquences
graves
nous pouvions y perdre notre navire ou
l'endommager point d'être obligée de
battre en retraite ce qui nous aurait
retiré du front pendant le temps des
réparations ou même définitivement dans
nos flottes de combat de nombreux
navires étaient utilisés pour la
reconnaissance
des avions était chargé d' explorer les
mers pour trouver les convois en
particulier ceux sans escorte
parfois ces navires marchands étaient
camouflés et équipés de canons
malheureusement la plupart des navires
et des convois qui naviguait sans
escorte étaient des navires qui n'en
portait aucune cargaison d'importance ou
qui étaient même vide mais ça ne vous
arrêtez pas avant d'engager et de
commencer à tirer
nous donnions toujours l'opportunité ou
convois de stopper et de seraing nous
attaquions ceux qui arboraient le
drapeau de guerre ou qui émettait des
appels au secours en morse à la radio
vient d'en capturer quelques navires la
plupart du temps nous opérions seul fait
le charme
horst held by the now agissez
indépendamment l'un de l'autre navire
était sous les ordres du commandant de
la flotte de combat bien que nous
appartenions à la même force
nous venions rarement au contact et la
fin sinon pour recevoir de nouveaux
ordres concernant notre poste où nos
zones de reconnaissance pendant la
campagne de l'atlantique
nous sommes restés en mer pendant neuf
semaines
le 7 avril 1940 la royal air force
observait des navires marchands
allemands faisant route au nord vers la
norvège ils filer droit vers les ports
de mardyck et le trauma yb
chaque navire déguisé en caboteur été
chargé de troupes d'assaut
l'allemagne était sur le point d'envahir
la norvège
aux côtés de la flotte se trouvait les
navires scharnhorst ignacio now
il y avait aussi les deux tiers de la
flotte allemande de sous-marins déployés
en protection des transports de troupes
pourtant repéré par la r f le brouillard
et les nuages bas et des rats dissimuler
les navires bien qu'alerter l'umf les
deux fut lente à réagir à la menace
les convois à tenir leur destination
sans encombre même si un des navires
marchands fut coulé par un sous-marin
polonais
un destroyer anglais qui avaient
également tenté d'intercepter la flotte
futé prônée par le croiseur allemand qui
clerc avait envoyé à l'entrée de la mer
du nord les troupes d'assaut allemande
embarqué effectuèrent cinq débarquements
distincts en norvège
oslo christiane semble bergen kromine et
narvik
pendant que les troupes aéroportées
s'emparer de l'aérodrome de stavanger
en dépit de la perte du blue shirts tous
les objectifs des allemands furent
atteints sans rencontrer de résistance
sérieuse de la part des norvégiens
au moment de l'invasion le 9 avril la
flotte anglaise avait pratiquement
rattrapé la flotte allemande
et tandis que les troupes débarqué sans
problème de féroces combats se
déroulaient rambert les pertes
allemandes et anglaises sur l'eau nous
avons participé à l'attaqué de la
norvège en avril 1940
normalement avant que les ordres
n'arrive
nous étions à l écoute des rumeurs qui
circulaient d'un navire à l'autre la
plupart d'entre nous fut cependant
surpris lorsque les ordres furent
données nous devions tous immédiatement
partir en mer s'en prennent les navires
étaient lourdement chargé et nous étions
accompagnés d'une flotte de destroyers
ses destroyers était bourré de munitions
d'armements et d'équipements da nous
avons navigué vers les côtes de norvège
est en route
on nous a annoncé notre destination
narry notre boulot était d'accompagner
nettoyer jusqu'au port de les protéger
pendant trente six entrées les troupes
débarqué que pour l'équipement et les
munitions étaient déchargés puis de les
protéger sur le chemin du retour de
voyage étaient difficiles vent violent
il la mer démontée
c'était pire pour les destroyers c'était
si agitée il ya un moment du matériel
pas ça par dessus bord et pas seulement
du matériel
quelques hommes aussi tombé à l'eau nous
avons finalement accompagné les
destroyers jusqu'à narni qu ils ont
déchargé
c'est au petit matin alors qu'il faisait
encore sombre jeune flotte anglaise nous
a rattrapés nous avons combattu le
cuirassé renault pendant deux heures le
fut aussi engagé nous avons réussi à
nous échapper a filé vers nos destroyer
car nous devions les sortir de là sans
dommage cependant nous avons été
informés que ce n'était plus nécessaire
car les anglais avaient attrapé les
nôtres sur le chemin du retour et qu'ils
étaient tous perdu
les missions que nous avons mené pendant
la campagne norvégienne des gens en
effet cinq de plus dur est généralement
une semaine
parfois elle durer trois semaines la
plus longue d'entre elles durant neuf
semaines ce qui est plutôt dur au milieu
de l'atlantique
nous avons navigué 18 mille milles
nautiques
en juin 1940 le charme horst held by the
now fille route au nord ayant reçu
l'ordre de lancer une attaque au nord de
la norvège
la campagne de norvège touchait à sa fin
après l'évacuation des troupes alliées
de narvik les allemands disposait
désormais d'une emprise solide sur tout
le pays
fatalement devait tenter d'intercepter
les navires transportant les forces
alliées en retraite
en mer le croiseur allemand prinz eugen
engage à un des navires de transport
britannique vide alors en route vers
narvik mais laissa un navire hôpital qui
l'accompagnait poursuivre sa route
lahoud fleet avaient déployé plusieurs
de ses navires les plus importants dans
la zone dans le porte avions hms
glorious
le scharnhorst et le cna is now
pérenne à la fumée les glorious à une
distance de 30 km
des destroyers anglais accompagnait le
porte avions
les deux navires allemands manoeuvre air
pour affronter les anglais
à une distance de 29 kilomètres le
charme poste ouvrit le feu
les tirs allemands furent efficaces et
après quelques minutes le glorious reçu
un tir direct il commença à brûler ce
qui voulait dire qu'il ne pouvait plus
lancer ses appels
les deux destroyers qui l'accompagnait
se placèrent pour le protéger et ouvrir
le feu contre les navires anneaux
la distance entre les belligérants se
réduisait
le bleu rious commençait à couler mais
les deux destroyers combattait avec un
grand courage
le premier fut rapidement coulé
le second l'ardente fut également touché
écoulée mais pas avant qu'il ne lance
quatre tortues
le charme horst reçu un impact direct
sur son tribord faisant un trou de 4
mètres sur 10 juste sous une des
tourelles principal
le navire a été sévèrement endommagée
nous ne savions pas encore à quel point
mais nous nous rendions compte que
c'était sérieux
le moteur centrale avaient été touchés
et inondé et les listes ne fonctionnait
plus et élégante elle est belle a de la
chance nous avons réussi à rejoindre
trondheim sur un seul moteur en b nous
pouvions entendre les arbres de
transmissions cogner lourdement
nous sommes tout de même parvenu à bon
port après une période de réparation à
brest le scharnhorst et l'ogc nice now
ainsi que le prinz eugen réussir une des
opérations les plus audacieuses de la
guerre il remontait la manche à pleine
vitesse
après les réparations effectuées à brest
nous avons reçu de nouveaux ordres
la bataille de l'atlantique était de
plus en plus difficile et tandis que
nous étions à l'encré bresse nous nous
avions apporté des bombardiers anglais
et eux savaient que nous étions là il
était nécessaire pour toute la flotte de
filet avant d'être attaqué il ya trois
options se présentent et nous pouvions
filet jusqu'en méditerranée via
gibraltar nous pouvions remonter
jusqu'en norvège pour rejoindre la
sécurité de la mer baltique
nous pouvions foncé à travers la manche
est et celle ci semblait la meilleure
option
les anglais cependant s'y attendait et
faisait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient pour
rendre la manche l'infranchissable nous
avons eu la chance au grand désespoir
des anglais de réussir notre sortie du
port une attaque de bombardier mais
c'était une nuit nuageuse
ils ne parvinrent pas nous stopper
nous avons eu la chance de ne pas être
détectées avant d'atteindre le point le
plus étroit de la manche
alors bombardé avec leurs batteries
côtières sans résultat car nous étions
juste au delà de la portée de leur canot
puis les avions arrivaient autour de
nous le champ
horst now le prinz eugen nous destroyer
les avions torpilleurs tout le monde
tirait comme des malades
les anglais avaient envoyé quelques
avions torpilleurs ils se sont approchés
de nous très courageusement pour nous
attaquer mais il était trop lent
ils n'eurent pas l'opportunité de tirer
une seule torpilles nous les avons
descendu les uns après les autres avec
nos batteries entière la chance était
vraiment de notre côté arriva et engagea
les chasseurs et bombardiers anglais
parvenant à descendre de nombreux avions
de la rs nos navires parvinrent à sortir
de la manche sans dommage
le charme horse continua pendant deux
ans à harceler les navires ali
mais en décembre 1944 il trouva une fin
violente
moment la bataille du cap nord il fut
engagé écoulée par des croiseurs alliés
seulement 36 de ses marins survécu
le 14 février 1939 la coque massive d'un
navire de guerre en cours de finition
glissa dans les eaux de hambourg
c'était le bismarck
pour le parti nazi ce fut un jour de
fête
un nouvel atout pour la puissance
allemande
un moment qui réjouit également le
führer
le bismarck est l un des plus solides un
des plus grands un des plus puissants et
des plus modernes cuirassé de toutes les
marines du monde
la légende du bismarck se construisit en
seulement 2 177 jours
seulement 2 177 jours entre son
lancement et son naufrage
l'imposant bismarck fut à l'origine d'un
des épisodes de mr les plus dramatiques
de toute la seconde guerre mondiale
pendant ce court laps de temps il fut
l'un des navires les plus puissants du
monde
ils avaient été équipées de la
technologie la plus moderne et la plus
avancée disponible
la variété et la puissance de son
armement le très haut niveau de son
équipage faisaient de ce navire une
machine qui semblait invincible
le bismarck qu'aucune marines du monde
ne pouvait contrebalancer était la
représentation d'une allemagne sur le
chemin de la victoire
justement l'été 1940
j'ai été affecté sur le cuirassé
bismarck
nous avons passé les quelques semaines
suivantes à découvrir le navire de
l'intérieur et de l'extérieur et à
apprendre comment le navire fonctionner
ensuite nos postes nous ont été
attribués
j'ai reçu l'ordre de rejoindre une
batterie de 380 mm à la batterie du
milieu je fus entraîné à manipuler ses
canons et tous les autres instruments du
poste puis nous sommes partis en mer
nous avons reçu l'ordre d'effectuer un
certain nombre d'essais en mer baltique
notre rôle était de tester les canons et
de tirer à blanc cet entraînement nous
étions parvenus à une cadence de tir
d'un obus toutes les six secondes
étant donné la taille de notre a retiré
lourde
c'était plutôt pas mal
les anglais attendait que le bismarck
bouge
alors que le puissant cura s'est passée
la côte de norvège il fut repéré
l'alertent fut transmise à l'amirauté à
londres
un avion de reconnaissance de la rff fut
envoyé pour confirmation
les photos aériennes envoyé à londres
corroborait re l'information c'était
bien le bismarck
il était à l'ancré cachée au fond d'un
fjord avec ses navires d'escort en train
de refaire du carburant
les personnes à bord ne soupçonnait que
nous avons été repéré par la rfm
par conséquent nous ignorions que les
anglais savaient que nous arrivions là
nous avons passé le détroit du danemark
le 22 c'est alors que nous avons
rencontrés pour la première fois deux
croiseurs anglais ont ces deux navires
sortir soudainement du brouillard nous
avons eu l'autorisation d'ouvrir le feu
l'un des deux a disparu à nouveau dans
le brouillard nous pouvions ni le voir
ni lui tirer dessus
les anglais avait le radar tout comme
nous mais le commandant de notre flotte
fit une erreur il nous assurera que les
croiseurs ne nous avait pas eu un visuel
et qu'en dépit des émissions radars
qu'ils avaient lancé vers nos navires
il n'avait pas reçu d'écho ce type de
radar est un efficace par cette météo
c'était fou
les croiseurs ce folk et norfolk a des
vues le bismarck accompagnée du prince
eugène et avait eu toutes les
informations grâce à l' alerte aux
précédentes
la nouvelle position fut transmise à
londres alors que le bismarck continuer
sa route un message fut envoyé au
cuirassé houde lui donnant les
coordonnées l'ordre d'intercepter et
d'engager le bismarck
le food était alors un navire capital au
sein de la royal navy l'équivalent du
bismarck pour les anglais
bien que vieillissant il était le navire
le plus puissant de la marine anglaise
et était considéré comme le meilleur
adversaire potentiel pour le cuirassé
allemand le coude
accompagnée par le prince of wales et
six destroyers manoeuvra pour séparer
les navires ennemis vers le détroit du
danemark
les navires se rapprocher les uns des
autres et se préparait à livrer bataille
lors du premier échange de tirs le food
et le prince of wales ouvrir le feu on
le bismarck le prinz eugen répliqué
instantanément dès la première minute un
obus du prince eugène touche al kuds
déclenchant un incendie qui s'étendit
rapidement à tous le navire
une énorme explosion suivie quelques
instants plus tard
le good coulé en quelques minutes après
avoir tiré seulement cinq ou six salles
de son équipage de 1400 hommes seulement
3 survécurent
après la destruction du good le bismarck
et le prinz eugen tournaire leurs canons
vers le prince of wales
celui ci fut également touchés et forcer
à cesser toute action offensive
pendant ce temps les deux navires
allemands filaire tho nord ouest à
travers les eaux danoises
nous avions pris trois impacts du good
dans le compartiment des moteurs à
l'avant du navire et l'autre sur la
catapulte de lancement nous avions des
morts nous avons navigué un peu avant
qu'il soit décidé que le prinz eugen
continue vers le groenland et que nous
le big bang fonction de rejoindre brest
afin de réparation le problème était que
la soudure entre la paroisse et la
deuxième salle des chaudières était
sérieusement endommagée et que l'eau
commençait à l'envahir nous étions
toujours en alerte est vraiment très
occupé quand de l'eau entre dans un
navire vous pouvez imaginer que c'est la
pire chose qui puisse arriver les gens
commencèrent à paniquer [__] la
situation commençait à se stabiliser
nous reprîmes nos postes de combat
respectif
le navire repris sa route à pleine
vapeur
pour les anglais la chasse commence et
et catalina des colères pour se joindre
à la traque cherchant dans le brouillard
et les nuages
il savait que le bismarck filait à toute
allure pour se mettre à l'abri
les catalina survolait l'océan et lui
une percée dans les nuages un sillage de
navire fut repéré
puis le navire fut aperçu
le signal fut envoyé à toute la flotte
la cible avait été repéré
en quelques minutes l'ark royal ainsi
que toute la force h se rapprochèrent de
la position
le temps a été particulièrement mauvais
dans la zone de la cible mais les
équipages savait qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autres navires dans cette zone le
sheffield reçu l'ordre de trouver et de
découvrir le bismarck
lacroix yann ne fut pas informés de ce
départ
les avions de l'ark royal volant dans
des conditions difficiles à repérer un
navire proche de la position où ils
s'attendaient à trouver le navire
allemand
persuadé qu'il s'agissait du bismarck
ils lancèrent leur attaque contre le ch
et fille
mais le sort se retourna contre le
bismarck
d'abord de l'ark royal les avions de
retour et et réarmer et réapprovisionner
en carburant
sous une pluie violente les soit en
fiche des colères pour une deuxième
attaque
le 26 au soir nous avons été attaquée
pour la deuxième fois par les soirs de
fiches anglais des avions torpilleurs
plus tard dans la nuit
une deuxième attaque eu lieu pq plus de
succès nous avons été touchés
nous avions tenté d'échapper aux avions
et aux torpilles mais à ce moment là
nous avons été touchés au gouvernail
il était salement amoché été tordus
environ 12 degrés après ça nous n'avons
pu avancer qu'à 8 à l'aide des moteurs
du côté opposé au gouvernail nous étions
seuls nous étions environ six heures en
avant de la flotte anglaise mais nous ne
pourrions plus nous échapper seulement
tourné en il nous avait tu prônes ce
saut vers 6 heures du matin et nous ont
rattrapés avons tenté d'accélérer mais
sans résultat nous ne pouvions plus que
tracer des cercles
nous n'avons pas tardé à réaliser que
nous étions des cibles faciles pour la
flotte anglaise
la flotte anglaise était composée du
dorset shire du king george 5 et du
roannais
il se rapprochèrent du bismarck
endommagés et ouvrir le feu
les tirs anglais se succédèrent par
salves pendant une heure entière
et
nous avons reçu deux tirs directs à
l'avant du navire
des équipes de la touraine remontait et
nous avertir de filer au plus vite car
la soute allait exploser d'une minute à
l'autre
les quartiers maîtres du navire donné
ordre à l'équipage de se retirer que
nous avons couru dans le navire vers nos
quartiers nous étions sous le pont
c'était la panique partout
les équipes des salles d'opération ceux
qui s'occupaient des machines et des
hélices avait donné l'ordre de la mesure
vais élever signifiant vers juncker
naufrage nous avions quinze minutes quoi
abandonné le navire
j'ai tenté d'ouvrir la porte de
l'écoutille mais c'était impossible à
cause des débris qui était tombé dessus
j'ai crié pour que quelqu'un au-dessus
tente de les bouger car départ chance
quelqu'un entendu mon cri et a pu les
déplacer j'ai laissé mes camarades
sortir en premier je me suis assuré que
la pièce est évident qu'un autre impact
sur le pont nous avons perdu de nombreux
hommes et beaucoup d'autres était
salement blessé
j'ai tenté d'aller vers l'arrière
c'était une erreur de ma part l'eau
était en train de l'envahir
je me suis donc sorti de là et je suis
montée au niveau supérieur
vous ne pouvez pas croire ce que j'ai vu
là j'étais sur le pont au niveau de la
tourelle césar il y avait au moins 50
peut-être sans cadavre vous ne pouvez
imaginer une telle vision d'horreur
en tout 100 hommes du bismarck furent
sauvés mais deux mille autres dont tous
les officiers avaient péri
le lotso fut lancée sous le nom de
deutschland
mais en février 1940 hitler décida que
la perte éventuelle d'un navire appelé
allemagne serait un très mauvais présage
et le nom fut changée en lucho en 1940
il prit part à la campagne de norvège
avant de naviguer plus au nord pour
menacer les convois alliés en route vers
la russie en décembre 1940 avec l'amiral
keeper il prit part à un raid contre un
convoi défendu par huit destroyer les
destroyers mené une attaque
impressionnante dans ce qui est
désormais connu comme la bataille de la
mer de barents
finalement les navires allemands furent
forcés d'abandonner leur raid
éclair rendu furieux d'une telle contre
performance décevante menaça de
dissoudre toute la marine
les relations entre le führer et le
grand amiral avait atteint un point de
rupture raider démissionner et fut
remplacé par l'amiral d'audit
le lucho fut envoyée dans la baltique
pour entraînement puis plus tard opéra
en soutien de l'armée contre les russes
en baltique orientale deux mois après le
lancement du bismarck son sistership le
tirpitz fut mise à l'eau avec 50 de 1600
tonnes le tirpitz étaient 2000 tonnes
plus lourd que le bismarck et avait un
armement et un équipage plus important
il fut envoyé en norvège en 1942
les nombreux fjords lui donnait de
nombreux points d'ancrage relativement
sûre
en septembre 1943 des sous marins de
poche appelé x craft parvint à entrer
dans le fjord et a endommagé les hélices
avec des mines
tous les x craft furent perdues dans
l'opération
en avril 1944 des avions embarqués
anglais lancé une attaque contre le dire
pics une fois de plus il fut endommagée
mais cette fois encore sans gravité
finalement à l'automne 1944 deux des
meilleurs squadron du combo recommande
attaquèrent le tirpitz entre warren ne
sais pas
le 12 novembre il le touche r si
sévèrement qu'il s'agira
le dernier des grands cuirassé allemand
avait vécu
les cuirassé allemand avait mené une
longue et dure guère héroïque
le graff chevet s'était sabordé dix
jours avant l'invasion de la pologne
alors que le look zoo était toujours en
action au moment de l'invasion russe
quatre jours avant la mort du führer
aucun des grands navires de combat ne
devait survivre au conflit
le 4 septembre 1939 112 passagers et
membres d'équipage du ss athéniens été
tuées en mer ce furent les premières
victimes de la guerre sous marine
allemande
cette attaque marqué le début d'une
longue campagne durant laquelle les
pertes furent lourde des deux côtés
entre septembre 39 et mai 45 les robots
de couleur 2600 trois navires marchands
et 175 navires de guerre alliés
environ 30 milles marins des cons
voilier moururent en mer
en contrepartie des 1162 ubud construit
pendant la guerre 784 furent comblés
et sur l'e40 1900 hommes affectés aux
sous marins près de 26000 moururent en
mer
en dépit de ses pertes effrayante le
moral des sous-mariniers allemand resta
toujours au plus haut
à la tempérance
en main 43 il subir des pertes si
lourdes qu'ils durent être retirés de la
bataille de l'atlantique
mais dès que de nouvelles tactiques et
de nouvelles armes furent prête le
combat repris
un retour en action similaire était
programmé pour 1945 mais n'eut jamais
lieu
les armées alliées s'étant emparée des
chantiers navals et des centres de
production
oh
nous